hey everybody we are back with Brandon
acre once again the incredibly talented
Brandon acre and he's not here with the
the--or bow today that we actually are
because we're filming another video but
today we're gonna be talking about the
baroque guitar what are we looking at
the Baroque guitar is a 17th century
version slow 1600s version of the guitar
because the predecessor to the modern
guitar if you were guitarist in the
1600s this is what you would be playing
this is what she we know and love and
it's almost like the guitar that we know
like if I pick it up now yeah and then
at first if you just look at its I've
been intimidating because I don't know
how many strings to this so there's
actually nine strings but this is a nine
string it's a nine string so if your
guitarist in the 1600s you play a nine
string that's not a totally new thing
like nine shrink guitars were standard
in the 1600 exactly right but the thing
is we don't think of them as nine
strings so it's important to actually
call this a five-course guitar of course
being a pair of strings so when I play
this instrument I think I have five
strings and four of them are doubled
like a twelve string guitar so in
essence it's like take the six string
that you know you get rid of the low E
and then double up all the strings
except for the high correct so the high
E has a really special name it's called
the chanterelle which is French which
means the singing string if you make the
high E single it makes them it brings
out the melody of that string a bit
boring how it compares to a regular
guitar we have no low E then two ace
high - I have higher oh you're right so
there is no low a I didn't realize that
in this tuning yeah octave higher than a
normal guitar yeah - is and then two
octaves of D one of them being the one
we're used to then G - geez - geez -
bézé
and 1e yeah and so mall lutes and
instruments of this period that had this
double stringing always kept the first
one the chanterelles singing similarly
yeah it's like you can hear it stands
out and so all the other strings A to B
here are doubled and it's the D that has
the octave it's nice that there is like
I can strum it just with the same muscle
memory that I have a regular guitar but
there's all these different textures for
each string that I'm used to because
they're either doubled up with the same
note doubled up an octave or just single
it really changes the way you play and
if you play the music that was written
for it you'll see they took full
advantage of that sound one of the
hardest things about playing this
instrument coming from single string
guitars is having to play both strings
at the same time yeah cuz you as a
guitarist you really end up going the
only [ __ ] one you have to learn how to
touch both strings at the same time
[Music]
that's a very different sound right
especially if there are the octaves
[Music]
plane hopefully that's like how to focus
at least it's not yeah that's just
filming outside oh yeah I guess do you
happen to know when they added the low E
and when did they stop doubling the
strings yeah it seems like it happened
just before 1800 the instruments were
slowly transitioning and
I've heard a good a good argument for a
sixth string becoming sort of codified
and becoming a standard 1800 around 1800
yeah just the beginning of the 19th
century and you know why they've made
that change so the guitar why did they
add the LOI it might sound like a weird
thing if you start with the baroque
guitar and then say why did someone have
the idea to add the load l OE but just
back up a couple hundred years they had
five or six course instruments and they
just the trend was to how many low bases
can we fit on the stage not new at all I
seen your videos with the all these low
Street I'm like he's basically and I
wonder if it was somewhat of a joke at
the time too
I don't think it's much that it's as
funny as it is like they wanted the low
bass playing well our waiting for this
plane take a quick coffee break with our
sponsor trade coffee I love coffee I
love a smell I have coffee every morning
and so this is a perfect sponsor for me
you have coffee a lot of afternoons -
yeah I'm mornings and afternoons shoes
trade partners with 50 of the best
Roasters in the nation and has over 400
types of coffee to choose from and trade
coffee personalizes it to you what type
of flavours you're into and how you like
to drink your coffee so when I took the
quiz on the website off matched metric
coffee paradigm Breakfast Blend medium
roast this is what I want to smell
anymore so I used to do French press but
just for the sake of convenience I just
went to trip I tap my coffee just with
cream and I put my cream in first so
that I don't need to stir it and with
trade I get to continue trying new types
of coffee flavors that I'm really gonna
enjoy made for the ways that I like to
make coffee trade is giving the first
hundred people who sign up with the link
below 30% off their first coffee
use the code Rob Scallon alright I think
the plains mostly gone now thanks again
to Train for sponsoring this video the
plan let's get back this so they just
wanted the low because what would
accompany this on the base side at the
time would it be the the or bow was that
a regular instrument to accompany this
you can do fewer bows with guitars you
can have cellos and cello like
instruments bowing the low bass
especially in the 17th century what we
call the Baroque period the bass is so
important in fact they kind of thought
of music from the base up and so you
need this very
which the fioor bow we found out in the
last video gives us do you know at what
time they stopped doubling the strings
as well and why did they make that
decision I've read that at the same time
around that they added the low sixth
string they also started moving things
to single strings as being the standard
because it's a little bit easier to be
more precise in virtuosic which fit the
music of the time the early 19th century
early romantic music we can call it no
longer baroque she's more technical so
they wanted to use more technical it's
that they were using different
techniques that the early romantic music
required was more well suited to single
strings certainly easier to tune it was
easier to to they also started going
with steel frets because you remember I
have these got frets mm-hmm then I can
slide around and change but freakin and
that are kind of wearing a bit yes you
play these are gut
these are gut people find a weird that
shoved my house and all of a sudden I
have all these bags of intestines and
this intestine is that this thickness
but that's you know you you collect all
different gauges of this material and it
gets really technical how you can tie it
on yourself and and find the right size
you know if you have like if you have
metal frets it's really hard to change
them you have to file them alone this I
can just cut it off and tie a different
one on but by 1800 we certainly start
getting more metal frets and single
strings that that just was the trend and
that's that's the one that your system
is old
well we know the guitar of it now what
makes this instrument sound so special
is what we're talking about that double
stringing because you can do really cool
things because it actually doesn't go
low to high there's kind of this
inside-outside thing kind of like a
ukulele mm-hmm and actually this is kind
of where the ukulele tuning comes from
really i-i've heard from from actually
the younger brother of this instrument
the renaissance guitar it's tuned just
like ukulele with that higher string up
top the cool thing about is instead of
playing scales like each string has a
different texture with a mean either
doubled up or doubled up with an octave
or the planes you're a particular type
of musician that plays instruments from
hundreds of years ago to the best
accuracy what is that what does that
called
you can call me an early musician early
musician specialist in early instruments
someone who's interested in and what's
called hip actually it's really informed
performance it is it it's super heavy
yeah that's another thing that's really
fascinating about this to me is you pick
it up and you play it and you feel this
connection to guitars from 1600 I think
of this sort of like a musical
archaeology yeah the really cool
experience when you look at this
manuscript in here like has anyone even
seen this for 400 years anyone played
this and when you play you're like it's
kind of a new music in a way because
it's so old that it's been rediscovered
how do you study that music because you
have the sheet music I'm sure yeah is
that enough you have to use your musical
intuition but you can read all these
texts and things sometimes in the
preface to like a book of their music do
they have descriptions of their playing
style as sometimes they talk about it
and sometimes they say things like put
your pinkie down on the answer
you know and like play halfway between
the bridge and the rose which is what we
call this that's the sound they want and
you know you can look at paintings to
advise you as well and the paintings
when you see baroque guitars they always
strum here which gives everything soft
[Music]
and then when they pluck they always put
their pinkie down by the bridge down
here and you have the fingernails for
that - yeah so that the nails thing is
kind of interesting we know that some
people played with nails and some people
didn't and no one played with guitar
picks at this time earlier they did
earlier they played with like Eagles
quills as plectrums yeah pretty it's
pretty cool pretty metal pretty metal
you use those paintings as a reference
for your playing now we got cicadas here
yeah so you'll never know how accurate
you are because we don't have any
recordings yeah 1600s I think the
earliest recording is like just a little
bit before whether early nineteen
hundreds or something very recently far
after these were first created exactly
and do you know plane like Wayne's are
all but in the end of the day there's
always a mixture of the hip part that
historically informed performance need
and then there's a mixture of what works
for our aesthetic one thing that I think
every musician has to do is be as
informed as possible and then you try to
make things sound good and do what they
want most of all
when is just going side we should
probably yeah once she's close to yeah
yeah let's change
here we can try a song oh that's from
yeah I learned that from doing slap bass
yes that's how it so it set up like a no
normally you're supposed to hit it with
your tribe your fingernail yeah but from
playing bass I'm just hitting it like
with the meaty part my fingers like
that's have a thing in Reverse that's
great
[Music]
it's not a person but I still get like
90% of the way there let's try a broke
to see
[Music]
professor
[Music]
I love this thing I absolutely love it
it's great right now you're you're
shredding over a baroque pieces it's so
great and also that's so in the spirit
of what's it's supposed to be actually
the pieces were just you know fun core
progressions and each like what can go
on top of it you know what's funny I
love about the theater bows once you get
used to the guitar playing there's some
pieces that sound really good like
[Music]
beautiful that's what's great is the
first finger picking song that I learned
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
take these broken wings
[Music]
yeah this has that just this incredible
sound that I'm not totally used to yeah
but a fretboard that I totally
understand exactly other really cool
thing about the poor guitar is you can't
miss as the sound hole decoration I had
this guitar made for me by this amazing
luthier in Spain
named Julio Castaignos and he showed me
the goat skin where that came from
that's goat skin really yeah and his
wife Mariana designed this the
decoration for me so it's
three-dimensional
we call it like a reverse wedding cake
rose and again purely aesthetic but it's
so gorgeous I love also is the the
mustache bridge not great yeah all the
wood work he did is so incredible if you
flip around the guitar the back he just
for looks he just added this extra strip
of maple in there among all the rosewood
I mean just that it is so beautiful and
up top you can see all this beautiful
layers of fine detail it's just gorgeous
student eggs are really interesting too
again just friction yeah but they work
beautifully actually which is an amazing
process watching them you know fit the
pegs it's incredible it's made to be hit
after you actually slap that's good how
are you hitting it a lot and make yeah
[Music]
I'd hold on a sec granted I'm gonna get
some coffee thanks again to our sponsor
trade coffee you can get 30% off your
first bag of coffee by using the link
below and using the coupon code Rob
Scallon Frank Branden where you going hi
well thanks for being on my channel
again so much you guys would like to
check out Brandon's channel that is
right here if you'd like to subscribe to
my channel that's here as well here's
some other videos we've done like this
and if you didn't see the one we did on
that the orb oh really check that out
also the music video we shot today with
it the orb own this it's a really good
representation of those two instruments
ah yeah we'll see you next week thanks
so much for watching
yes